hey guys what's up this is andrew from
sentences.com so it's been one week i
didn't do a video sorry guys i'm very
very busy on many things uh but of
course i'm monitoring the market every
day i'm with you guys in code
um we had
a major breakout last week on many
stocks without volume
um
so
let's see what happened let's analyze
the situation again
uh i'm going to give you my view um and
let's see what can happen next let's get
into it
oh right guys so uh first amc
last week i told you guys we had this
major move up
very strong we had a nice volume
increase here all right so it's always
positive to see those uh volumes
increasing together with the breakouts
so this breakout to me and we close at
the top of the day so this breakout to
me was good quality
we only missed a nice consolidation here
you see we had here the candles quite
far from the resistance so for the
breakup to be perfect we would have
liked not to have this all right and to
have this higher so that the price
action is really you know building up
energy just below the resistance and
then breaking out but still it was a
good breakout and the rsi was positive
so i was here positive i wanted to buy i
didn't buy because we opened here and in
the end it was a good decision because
then we dropped so
what is the situation now
uh only looking at amc to me this is
totally fine
uh we are just you know pulling back
here i'm a bit more concerned about the
rest of the markets so
let's see
i'm going to explain why but on amc we
are above the 20-day moving average
we're still above the breakout level so
we pulled back here quite brutally but
we came back to the 61.8 fib ratio so
this is a nice level to buy
um i might buy some more shares on
monday here
it's a good level
uh stop loss i would use a stop loss
just below
the
78.6 percent so roughly you know around
this area
so actually just here guys all right so
this is a good risk we will trade
uh you know buy 12.5 stop loss 11.8
something like that i think this is what
i posted in my discord by the way
okay we're gonna have a look at that
later uh but i'm positive here but of
course guys uh we've seen bears very
very strong in the past few months so
you know it's also very possible that we
just drop lower so that's why a stop
loss is here a very
um good way to mitigate the risk
so jimmy
gme as usual guys jimmy's looking quite
good
uh it's
you know we dropped here quite heavily i
bought here personally on monday i
bought a call um it's worth almost
nothing now but you know this is how
calls are working uh so that i'm
protecting on the way down and
i'm gonna make money only if there is a
very strong move up so what is happening
here
is that we are
consolidating just here yes what is that
okay
sorry
sorry guys
uh so we are consolidating just here
as you can see
so consolidation like that
uh is good because we're building up
energy
um so if we break out above 140
it's probably going to be brutal it's
not going to be easy to trade so
um
i'm not sure what i'm going to do
but
and but if we close above 140 not too
far from 140 it's a good level to buy it
looks to me that we want to push higher
and re-test this measure resistance and
here question either we drop or we
finally break out and this could be the
beginning of a squeeze once again for
this to happen you know that we need the
rest of the market to be bullish so
let's see let's see
um but here
uh bam bam bam
yeah
we are consolidating it looks to me like
a fourth wave maybe
you know it could be something like that
could be i don't know
uh
but this consolidation is to me quite
you know
um
usual i would say
we can clearly see the 137 level acting
as resistance this level has been here
for quite some time guys this is the
level i'm having
and we can see that it is where bears
are located so
let's find out to me this price action
is still bullish as you can see rsi much
higher than 50
uh very strong volume on the way up not
on the way down
macd going higher
you know this is quite positive to me
if we take a step back we
are in a massive triangle as you guys
can see
when you use the logarithmic scale so
this is where we want to break out
a very possible scenario is that we just
stay in there a little bit longer that's
possible as well
let's see but 160 is the
next target next resistance i think
we're gonna go there
um
i'm not sure we're gonna be able to
break it right away to be honest but
let's see what the rest of the market is
doing now triple q the rest of the
market is here so
what do we have uh i was very positive
this week
for triple q
uh
i gave you guys some
uh trades here
so i was saying to buy
uh
at three or five it was a little bit
higher
increase the position on the way down
and stop loss around 288 all right so as
long as we're above 288 to me we're
still you know in this
uh medium-term reversal that happened as
you can see after a nice consolidation
on low volume the only problem here is
that we don't have the volume on the way
up but once again triple q is an etf you
guys know that etfs i mean etf offer
global index you know that
[Music]
those instruments trade more whenever
there is panic so it's acceptable not to
have a strong volume increase but what
i'm worried about is that we don't see
this volume increase even on single
stocks
i'm going to show you a few examples so
here i'm still positive rsi you know
hovering around 15 now 49
was trading rather above 15 macd going
higher this is positive
and we have this breakout so this
breakout is not perfect
it's actually not that good because
i mean the consideration is here but on
a daily time frame
we can see that we moved higher without
actually taking a breath so in this
situation usually a pullback is
happening so i'm going to be here to buy
this pullback towards the 290 300 area
and then i think that we might go higher
um
so this is my view for now
i don't have
much more to say i can show you a few
breakouts that we had this week alright
so rxrx
this way this one is a good uh breakout
uh i gave you this trade guys here this
is a
pharmaceutical company uh very promising
i'm monitoring the stock for quite some
time and here you can see we have no
this is a nice consideration look guys
all right this is a nice consideration
you can see the price action
very very close to the resistance on
very low volume all right
uh and this trend line has been tested
multiple times so one reaction
two
reactions okay it's not the perfect
trend line here it's not touching but
here one two reactions and here the
consideration is really nice then we
break out the only issue i had here and
this is
what i'm seeing on most most single
stocks is that we don't have the volume
increase on the way up
um it's still
pushed higher here
and those who follow my course i'm was
very happy to see in my discord that uh
you remember what's the right way to
trade this
whenever we have a breakout like that
especially when whenever it's not a nice
i mean a perfect breakout with strong
volume increase uh it's good to take
fifty percent of the profits on the
first recent high so here six seventy
six eighty even 690
um and then to use a training stop loss
all right to find to find your training
stop-loss you just connect
you use the 20-day moving average or you
connect the lows of the recent move up
all right so here roughly around 570
just between the moving average and this
is exactly what jay told me thank you
brother i'm very happy to see that you
follow the course
so right now the next target is 8.8 uh
let me show you tesla guys i gave you as
well this trade
so
for now it's not working very well
but it's i mean
of course i didn't tell you to buy
on the top uh i gave you this trade to
buy at 7.25
i don't remember actually 725 i think i
said to buy a little more
at 6.90 let's check
all right exactly so 725 695 stop loss
675. this was tesla so so 695 has not
been executed yet
uh but this is to me once again so i
told you guys in my discord it's a risky
play because
uh no consideration before no volume
increase so this breakout could very
well be a fake out that's why we use a
stop loss i personally didn't get in the
straight because the breakout was not
good enough to me
but i still share this trade and telling
you clearly that
without consideration without volume and
this breakout is not good quality i'm
still giving it to you guys because i
know you follow tesla
but i personally didn't trade this
uh and the stop loss around 675. so you
see this is what we see in most stocks
that i've seen a lot of them are coming
close to resistance as well such as
apple amazon
so i mean
it looks bullish but let's be very very
careful because we have a lot of bearish
signs as well now let's finish by
looking at the u.s standard yield
uh it's you you guys know it's a very
good indicator and
i don't really like what i'm seeing
because we were pulling back nicely
uh last week
and we can see that we just came close
to resistance guys this is a typical
i mean
you know
typical breakout situation break out
re-test i hope we won't push higher
because if we do
it's not going to be good for the market
all right so you can see we broke out we
retested the trendline and now
a nice scandal up plus seven percent
this week so let's hope this is just
gonna fade if it's not fading we're
gonna have problems dxy following the
same kind of pattern
breakout above 103 pullback to the
50-day moving average finding support
here
still below 103 but definitely this
chart is bullish guys alright it's
pretty obvious that we are going higher
uh and i just hope that
we're gonna have a reversal here for now
we don't have strong signs of reversal
we just have a pullback that could very
well be followed by another move up
if this happens it's not good for the
market so
um i'm still having roughly the same
kind of view i told you last week that i
think we're gonna be bullish this week
um
i mean was bullish on tuesday so i was
a little bit right here but then just
you know got destroyed jimmy stable
triple q bullish and pullback but we're
still trading higher than last week uh
do we actually
no we're we're training slightly lower
okay we moved down by uh
one percent so roughly flatish but
let's be honest we finished at the low
of the week we had a nice bullish week
to me on triple q
we had some opportunities on stock but
as
expected
this breakout has not been followed by a
massive move up it's hovering
with finding some stability let's see
what we're gonna have this week i'm a
little bit less bullish than i was last
week but we still have some positive
signs
um
so let's see let's see what we're gonna
have guys um i'm gonna try to make more
videos this week the reason why i make
less video guys is because i have my
mint coming in two weeks guys so if
you're not in crypto booze
um this quote come there guys we have
the hype coming we're gonna be sold out
very very quickly
the first mint is cheap so if you come
quickly i can still manage to get some
white lists for you
i know that a lot of you already there
you have your white list just be on time
during when the mint is going to come
i'm i'm gonna be i'm gonna have more
time afterwards but like for the next
two weeks i'm gonna be very busy on this
um
so yeah that's it for this video i hope
you guys enjoyed it and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys